So, what brings
you two to Akumal?
Vacation
from the kids?
Oh, no kids.
That ship has sailed.
It's our ten year
anniversary.
Take these, as they
will get you
everything you need.
Even heroin?
Sorry?
She's joking.
That was a bad joke.
I'm starting to
forget who I am.
No work, no stress,
no regrets.
Why don't we just see
where this leads us?
This phone belonged
to a kid who went
missing down here
fifteen years ago.
It belonged to
Sam Lawford.
Sam, and his mom,
and his dad
and his girlfriend arrived
at this resort
on Christmas night.
But then, the
next morning,
he's gone.
Later on, this other
guest from the resort
was also
reported missing.
Do you want to
get out of here?
My daughter wanted
to spend Christmas here.
But she didn't want
to spend it with me.
We found the
boy's skateboard.
Do you ever feel like something from the past
is missing from your future?
I'm gonna get
some answers.
Hey, come back here!
But what if there
aren't any answers?
Well, there have to be,
because otherwise what
is the fucking point?